you also chose to stay in the same city
yeah and i have such respect for that i
moved from california to new york
so that the girls would be 10 blocks
from their dad and not across the
country
i get it i get it listen this is the
thing drew this was way
back when oprah had her show and she was
talking about giving the show
up because she wanted to go into acting
she wanted to go into acting she wanted
to act full-time because she loved
acting
so her plan was you move to chicago and
we'll incorporate you in the show
so that at the end for a year so at the
end of the year then i can sort of pass
a baton and i was
really imagine a huge opportunity i was
really excited about that
and the kids were you know we
were divorced so they were still young
and then i realized that that wouldn't
be fair to them
that that wouldn't be fair to them would
be great for me be really great for me
but that wouldn't be fair to them and so
in the end i decided
to not take her up on that offer but
kirby
favorite daughter kirby favorite son
will their well-being to me
was more important than whatever career
opportunity i
i could have had at the time and i don't
regret that
you probably don't either do you moving
ultimately
um i ended up finding my way
tremendous happiness a wonderful group
of friends
um a life that was conducive and the
thing that gave me the
most happiness was though i couldn't
control
making a marriage that didn't work work
and the failure and the guilt and the i
mean i've never felt it took me down for
five years i
i couldn't function it was as if i was
letting them down
and but you're not letting them down you
know i had a husband that didn't believe
in monogamy
i happen to think that's important in a
marriage and so
you know you you you're not really
letting them down because you're still
their mother he's still their father and
you're still going to raise him with
an abundance of love so you're not
letting them down
thank you and it is amazing to hear that
from my parenting
icon and
the one thing i knew i could control is
that if i put
my compass my north star in their best
interest that no matter what happened
everything would be okay